[Music]
final debate is tonight tonight
President Obama and Mitt Romney hold
their final debate in Boca Raton Florida
yeah oh you're the topic of the debate
is what's more shocking to see in Boca
Raton a Mormon or a black guy there's
for you people who are from Boca Raton
you're from Boca Raton you just lied to
hear yourself on TV all right tonight
you know and the debate will have
happened by the time this airs we tape
the show nine months early we don't know
who the Republican candidate is yet no
no we tape a little bit or Herman Cain
all the way we're just guessing at this
no we tape a little a few hours early so
it hasn't happened yet but tonight
President Obama and Mitt Romney debate
foreign policy that's the topic
pundits say it will be close who woos
foreign policy
this is the most sarcastic crowd hey
gang tonight it's fuzzy
yes foreign-policy tonight pundits say
it will be close but the edge will
probably go to the candidate wearing the
I killed Osama bin Laden t-shirt
according to the New York Times I found
this interesting the Google search Paul
Ryan shirtless is nine times more
popular than the Google search Paul Ryan
budget
yeah the awkward part is most those
searches have been traced back to Joe
Biden's laptop Donald Trump is in the
news Donald Trump says he will reveal
big news about President Obama on
Wednesday yeah Trump said he would have
announced it sooner but faking a Kenyan
birth certificate is harder than it
looks
today Lance Armstrong was formally
stripped of his seven Tour de France
titles due to his doping scandal on the
on the plus side he did just receive a
Nobel Prize in Chemistry
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys excited about Halloween yet so
it's Halloween and foreign-policy it's
that kind of crowd yeah yeah if you
could combine the two this year
Americans will spend eight billion
dollars on Halloween costumes eight
billion dollars folks it's not a good
sign when the only bright spots in our
economy are candy and dressing like a
[ __ ] or is it yeah I love the [ __ ]
guess what Switzerland's been going on
for years what the hell was that Swiss
chocolate
the Swiss are slow
[Music]
you know how many emails we're gonna get
about that that's what those big horn
sports like come and get the sex
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all their cuckoo clocks are begging for
said extra time for sex I got big news
I'm working on new moves out here
ladies and gentlemen Adele has given
birth to a baby boy yeah witnesses say
Adele howled in agony for nearly ten
hours then had to cut her recording
session short when she went into labor
thank you
what's that what's that you you want
another Redell giving birth joke that's
true over the weekend
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there and demanding it yeah
it's not like I have it written on a
card
[Laughter]
that's true folks over the weekend Adele
did give birth to a baby boy that's true
yeah so once again Adele started crying
after a male left her
[Applause]